♪
>> Judge Jeanine: IT'S TIME NOW
FOR ONE MORE THING AND GREG, YOU
GO FIRST.
>> Greg: FIRST OF ALL, WE HAVE
GREAT SHOW TONIGHT.
WE HAVE ON MY SHOW, SOMEBODY BY
THE NAME OF DANA PERINO,.
>> Dana: SHE IS TERRIBLE.
>> Greg: JAMIE LISSOW, GUY
BENSON AND KAT TIMPF.
ALL STARS.
TAKE THAT BRET BAIER.
LET'S DO THIS, GREG, WATCH THIS
CAREFULLY.
A BUDDY WHO LIKES TO JUGGLE
HOOLIHAN HOOPS.
MAYBE YOU SHOULD GET A REAL
JOBS.
HE LIKES TO JUGGLE HIS HULA
HOOPS.
WATCH THIS CAREFULLY BECAUSE
SOMEBODY CAN HAPPEN THERE.
OH, SEE THAT?
JUGGLING HULA HOOP AND THE
SEALING CAME AND TOOK HIS HULA
HOOP.
I BELIEVE YOU BUT I STILL CAN'T
SEE IT.
I ARE THED OUT A GO FUND ME PAGE
TO HELP REPLACE HULA HOOP UP TO
$17 MILLION.
>> THANK YOU.
>> I LOVE THIS STORY.
ARE YOU READY FOR MY ONE MORE
THING?
IT CAUGHT MY ATTENTION A NEW
GROUP.
AMERICAN.
AND THEY ARE IN UPSTATE NEW YORK
IN ROCHESTER, THEY ARE REFUGEES
WHO HAVE PREVIOUSLY VOTED FOR
DEMOCRATS WITH YOU NOW FEEL
THEIR VOICE
♪ HEARD.
PART OF THE ROCHESTER POLITICAL
ADVOCACY AND ENGAGEMENT GROUP.
AND ON BEHALF OF THE OF THE
REFUGEE COMMUNITY THEY ARE
ENDORSING POLITICAL CANDIDATE
RON SINGLETARY FOR CONGRESS.
THEY SAY SAFETY IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE TO THEM AND
SINGLETARY CREATED A LIAISON
WITH THIS GROUP VIOLENCE IN
ROCHESTER IS REALLY HIGH.
YOU KNOW THAT A REAL PROBLEM.
A FORMER POLICE CHIEF.
THESE ARE 60 COMMUNITY LEADERS
FROM BUTAN, BURMESE, SOMALI,
INDIAN, TRINIDAD.
AFGHAN COMMUNITY.
IN MY OPINION, THIS SHOWS
DEMOCRACY IS NOT DYING TOMORROW.
PRETTY COOL.
>> Jesse: REFUGEES FOR
REPUBLICANS I HAVE BEEN SAYING
THAT FOR YEARS.
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE I SAID THAT
DOWNLOAD THE FREE AND I ELM IN A
SIZE FREE FOX BET SUPER 6 APP.
AND PLAY THE ELECTION CONTEST
FOR A CHANCE TO WIN $25,000.
YOU CAN BUY A LOT OF HULA HOOPS.
PICK AND WIN.
DOWNLOAD AND PAY FOR FREE.
TONIGHT, "JESSE WATTERS
PRIMETIME," I DO MY MIDTERM
PREDICTIONS.
AND IF I'M WRONG, JUST DELETE
THE DVR.
LIKE IT NEVER HAPPENED.
>> Greg: JUST LIKE THE MARATHON.
>> Jessica: THAT WAS REALLY
CRAPPY OF YOU, GREG.
AS YOU KNOW THE NEW YORK CITY
MARATHON TOOK YESTERDAY.
WHAT YOU PROBABLY DIDN'T KNOW
THE HULK WAS IN ATTENDANCE.
YOU WERE MEAN ABOUT A LITTLE
KID.
>> Greg: KNOW WASN'T.
WILL.
>> Jessica: YES, YOU WERE.
SHARON WHO WON IN THE WOMEN'S
DIVISION.
BOTH OF WHOM ARE FROM KENYA.
INCREDIBLE PERFORMANCES YOU,
JUST A FUN DAY.
>> Jesse: EVERY YEAR THEY WIN.
>> Jessica: KENYANS?
>> Judge Jeanine: EVERY YEAR.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
NOW IT'S MY TURN.
SOMETIMES JUSTICE SERVES ITSELF.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS VIDEO FROM
WASHINGTON STATE.
THIS BRAZEN THIEF THOUGHT HE WAS
GETTING AWAY WITH OVER $18,000
WORTH OF HANDBAGS FROM LOUIS
VITTON.
INSTEAD HE RAN DIRECTLY INTO A
PLATE GLASS WINDOW AND KNOCKED
HIMSELF OUT WHILE TRYING TO MAKE
OFF WITH THE GOODS.
THE 17-YEAR-OLD SUSPECT IS PART
OF A RETAIL CRIME GANG KNOWN IN
WASHINGTON.
HE THOUGHT HE WAS GETTING AWAY
WITH IT, THE POLICE DIDN'T EVEN
HAVE TO RUSH TO GET HIM.
HE WAS UNCONSCIOUS.
NOW, THAT'S WHAT I CALL LAW AND
ORDER.
RIGHT, GREG?
>> Jesse: I COULD WATCH THAT
EVERY DAY.
>> Greg: MORE GLASS DO